[Music]
what better way to start the year than
by being captivated by the wits and
intelligence of some anime protagonists
maybe these people are masters of
deception maybe they hold the key to
eternal life or maybe
they just like flexing their brain power
and solving mystery after mystery genius
is quite the relative term after all
whatever the case get ready to just
marvel at the protagonists of these
shows so here we are the top 10 anime
with the genius main character
before we get started i'd like to
encourage you to hit that subscribe
button
so that you can be very first to every
vini tube video next time let's begin we
start off with something pretty simple
how about a wholesome chill mystery
anime in hyouka
it's been a while since i've heard of
hyouka and that's to be expected
considering that it's been a while since
the anime ended and much of the talk
these days has been centered on a
suspiciously similar protagonist for
oreki yes
i'm talking about you hachiman now the
two shows differ quite a lot mind you
the most basic distinction is that
hyorka
is a mystery anime and a damn good one
at that at first i didn't expect a show
featuring your standard
broody cynical light novel hero and a
club mystery to catch my attention that
much but yorka surely did the job it did
so thanks in large part to the actual
mystery segment but even the show's
overall aesthetics visuals and
characters were all pretty amazing and
immersive a brilliant way to exercise
your brains i'd definitely recommend
hyoga to anyone looking to pick up their
first mystery anime it'll surely flip
that switch for you and get your
curiosity juices rolling
[Music]
how could we have a list of anime with a
genius protagonist without what many
people believe to be the granddaddy of
mystery and crime solving anime out
there detective conan is likely not the
first major mystery anime with a genius
protagonist
nor is it the undisputed best one
however there's no denying its legacy
and anime fans of all ages know of the
never aging kid detective
it doesn't even baffle me as to why the
series has endured the test of time
detective conan overall is a fun show
yeah i mean a lot of times it runs off a
pattern the mysteries and cases are
quite varied enough though
and each series of episodes can be a joy
to watch as you try to solve the cases
alongside our genius protagonist and his
friends detective conan is the
definition of a time sink if you've seen
one but it's one that has some excellent
and well-written episodes to help you
exercise your mental prowess
it's really designed to be a show
without a foreseeable end because of how
open it is
and that my friends is the secret to its
longevity
next on the list is log horizon
elder tales a vr mmo featuring a
post-apocalyptic earth where magic and
fantasy have overcome the modern
technology that we've grown comfortable
with it sounds like a really cool game
to play right that is
until you find yourself trapped inside
and able to log out with no way to get
out of the game
the players must then learn how to get
accustomed to this new world well
at least death's not permanent and you
have a brainy strategic protagonist this
time around
that is log horizon in a nutshell
trapped in a video game has been a tried
and true concept for quite some time now
but i think that log horizon especially
excels among those because of a few key
things while the previous shows
generally show more of the action
aspects of a video game lock horizon is
more focused on world building the focus
isn't on escaping but more on exploring
the world and settling into the new
reality found inside
elder tale along with that comes some
really amazing moments of character and
world development and it's the whole
exploration of the host of rules and
societies that makes log horizon its own
brand of exciting if you're up for an
isakai slash video game show and are
tired of all these
power fantasy saturating the genre then
this anime
is the one for you and with the new
season airing this season it's a perfect
time to catch up with log horizontally
on the contrary now if you're craving a
genius protagonist in an over-the-top
power fantasy it's a guy
no game no life is the show for you i
basically summarize no game no life for
you but to elaborate more the story
revolves around sora and shiro
siblings known as blank gods of games
the real world is just too boring for
them so they found themselves falling
into the colorful world of disboard a
realm where fighting is not allowed
and all conflicts are to be settled with
games finding themselves the champions
of humanity the humans and the weakest
among the 16 races in the world the
siblings set off to fight for humanity's
future and to eventually challenge the
world's god itself along the way they
meet friends and foes that will push
their gaming skills to the limit if
you're up for power fantasy
fan service overload and just some over
the top action
you can't go wrong with no game no life
it's just an amazing show
that pretty much embodies all those
polarizing traits of the modern isekai
including
the painful lack of a season 2 but hey
at least you've got a movie
one of the best anime titans i've
watched mind you to make up for it
on the other hand if what you want is
more world building
and actual education from the geniuses
of the anime world you might want to
check out dr stone
how will the world end some say that it
will end in a bank consumed by fire
others have quite the different
perspectives such as the one in dr stone
in dr stone the world comes to an
end through petrification with the
entire human race being turned to stone
and eternity later daiju breaks free
from his stone prison to meet up with
his old friend
sengku being the lone survivors of the
human race the two moved to set senko's
grand plan
into motion first order of business
would be to solve the mystery of the
petrification
second the two of them will pioneer the
revival of civilization from zero and
they'll do it
with the power of science dr stone is an
up-and-coming sci-fi adventure series
that's been stirring up
quite some waves in the anime scene
besides being unexpectedly educational
in a lot of its concepts and
storytelling it also blends science with
mystery to create an engaging narrative
that will keep you watching
episode after episode it even has
another season coming so now's the best
time to hop
in and start catching up to this series
which i feel could be a serious
contender for 2019's anime of the year
now for a much bleaker look at the fight
for survival i bring you
the promise neverland at first glance
the promise neverland doesn't seem to be
a dark and bleak show that is
until you find out the secrets of the
grace field house what looks like an
orphanage where children live happily
together
turns out to be a harvesting factory
where the children are set off to be
eaten by demons
discovering this dark secret the
protagonist trio of emma norman and rey
must trust their wits in cunning to
hatch a plan to help the remaining
children escape their cruel fate
doing so won't be easy not with mama
isabella keeping watch
the promise neverland combines the
thriller horror and psychological genres
in a really entertaining package
that's more than a sum of its parts
watch for the premise and stay for the
production values and twists and turns
of the story
it is for me one of the best anime shown
in the past two years
and i cannot wait for season 2 which is
airing right now
is there a more apt appearance for an
anime genius than a mad scientist it's
no surprise that stein's gage made it to
the list rintaro
okabe someone who would gladly roll with
the mad scientist monica the appearance
is there the love of gadgets and
technology is there and the imagination
is there too his life takes another
insane twist when he accidentally
stumbles upon the secret of time travel
fun and amazing right unfortunately his
fantasies about being involved in
government conspiracies end up striking
too close to home as well our genius
protagonist
finds himself in the crosshairs of an
underground organization
looking to unravel the secrets of time
travel agave must find a way to
outmaneuver this organization
while saving those he holds dear from
seemingly inevitable deaths now it's
been quite a while but stein's gate is
one fun ride if you're looking for a
thriller anime that involves some time
travel shenanigans this show is probably
one of the best ones out there the
characters are dynamic and engaging the
plot will keep you on the edge of your
seat
and everything comes down to one
thrilling climax
[Music]
we proceed with one of the most enormous
space operas in anime history
legend of the galactic heroes adapted
from a series of 10 novels
legend of galactic heroes tells of a
world with two major superpowers the
galactic
empire and the free planets alliance
backed by their respective trump cards
reinhard von lohengram and yangwen lee
the two major powers have been engaged
in a decade-long conflict
this serial primarily tells of the
battle between the two tactical geniuses
long and filled with detail to the brim
legend of galactic heroes earned its
legacy through its very intricate take
on world building and politics
it's become one of the most recognizable
names in all of anime
despite not a lot of people having
watched it at least from my personal
circles does that make it an anime that
deserves a lot more love well watch some
of the anime's 110 episodes
and see if you can make your personal
verdict on it or of course you can just
watch the 2018 remake with its way
shorter episode count
to cap things off we'll enter
megalomaniac a moral genius and it's a
toss-up between the two shows that
define the late 2000s for me i'll start
off
by placing death note here
[Music]
yes i'm fully aware that it's now 2021
and that a number of you are quite new
to the whole anime thing and weren't
around in the 2000s how about i
introduce you to one of the most beloved
titles to ever come out of the shonen
jump magazine
in death note the world's seen better
days and we're plagued with a lot of
problems regarding crime and justice
what better way to fix that than to
purge all the criminals by your own
hands right
like yagami would at least agree with
you and he gains the means to do so with
a magical notebook that allows him to
kill
anyone by just writing their names in it
taking up the mantle of kira light seeks
to cleanse the world of criminals in a
way no justice system could however such
a reckless way of striking fear into
criminals attracts the attention of the
police and they recruit the help of the
super detective
l to track down the being known as kira
then begins one of the most iconic
battles of cat and mouse with two
top tier geniuses trying to outmaneuver
one another who'll come out on top with
the fate of the world on the line
watch death note to find out you won't
be disappointed by either the battle of
wits or the relevant social commentary
that makes you second guess thing
[Music]
with light yagami playing second fiddle
by just a hair you know who's coming
next
none other than the magnificent lelouch
star of the legendary code kias
[Music]
i think it's arguable that code geass
has become one of the most popular mecca
titles in all anime history it has one
of the most enduring legacies in the
medium
period probably only matched by
evangelion or just a few other shows
all for a good reason of course and
though it's not death note with meccas
as many people would like to say but to
be fair the comparisons are warranted to
some extent
both series have more intellectual
battles than your standard shonen show
and both start a super genius anti-hero
protagonist both have also been gifted a
world-changing power which pushes them
to seek the world's upheaval it's just
that one outright kills
and the other uses mind control however
i think that code geass just does a lot
more as an anime in terms of blending
its components
you have the shonen fights and the
meccas the pretty boys and girls
a lot of mental battles and a very
intricate plot that creates so many
subplots all coming together to make
code geass one of the best watches
even to this day it's no surprise that
the thing became a runaway success
that's still getting milked but
enough of that the best way for you to
see a show's merits is for you to watch
it yourself so if you're looking for a
title starring a genius main character
look no further code geass
is your pin and there we have it have
you watched all of them care to share
some recommendations of your own the
comment section is all
open for you to share your thoughts
before you leave don't forget to like
and subscribe ring the bell so that
you'll be the first in line the next
time i upload a video there's still more
to look forward to from this channel in
2021 and i hope that you'll be here for
it
i'll see you next time on vini tube
you